chez les voyageurs l'ancien joueur des
saguenéens de chicoutimi dans la ligue
de hockey junior majeur du québec guy
carbonneau les souvenirs remontent à la
surface
un jeune qui va définitivement joué pour
le canadien de montréal guy carbonneau
guy carbonneau est un des joueurs les
plus prometteurs dans la clio 39 ans
l'entraîneur chef du club école des
nordiques faisait l'éloge de jeunes
joueurs de la filiale du canadien qui
attendait sa chance
j'aime ont été jetés à ce projet de
jouer j'ai fait l'avoir renvoyé la
maison ça se fera
[Applaudissements]
formation 16 jacques demers avait vu
juste ensemble lui guy carbonneau ont
même gagné la coupe stanley en 1993
guy carbonneau c'est l'histoire d'un
garçon s'est il auteur d'une saison de
182 points chez les juniors qui se
transforme en spécialiste des missions
défensives coéquipiers de carbo à
chicoutimi puis à montréal
gilbert delorme a vite remarqué sa
capacité d'adaptation car vous était
assez indulgent lui poser tabarouette
mombasa
suite même à l'ambiance d'un bus qui
passe les détails
un trophée mais n'en la légion à du
québec et à mon nom justement pour le
meilleur joueur défensif ce missile fans
ne vois que tu as laissé un impact à
quelque part ce qui a fait la renommée
de guy carbonneau
c'est cette rivalité avec l'as joueurs
des nordiques à chaque fois chaque fois
effectivement à cinq adhérents jean ce
qu'on nous au je pense que jouer
constamment compte twitter has tacheny
et puis c'est en désavantage numérique
je jouais
douzaine plus fois par année contre vie
aurait aussi des bas frustré souvent
mais jamais dépasser certaines limites
c'est pour ça qu'ils étaient toujours
john commun sur la droite chez les
canadiens de montréal
la moisson s'est avérée excellente
habits carbonneau a finalement gagné
trois trophées sow qui est remis au
meilleur attaquant défensif et la tâche
de capitaine du canadien lui a été
confié ça jamais été un poids je pense
que c'est quelque chose qui était
naturel sylvain capitaine mais les a
accompagnés à montréal et adam avant son
départ pour cette soirée en son hommage
guy carbonneau arrivait mal à cacher son
excitation particulière et le bout de la
fin revient à pitre tâche lui était
aussi un bol d'air lajoux est rodé du
col du canadien jean françois poirier
radio canada amauri